I would like to humbly apologize for
Sean's ineptitude wait let me rephrase
that he wouldn't know what that word
meant me big sorry for Sean's small
brain mister jacksepticeye has made a
horrible air and bungled all of the
prices on cloak brand calm this is my
fault really
it is it's my fault for expecting them
to know how to do math let alone know
what numbers even are and even worse in
his insane fumbling of the inner
workings of cloak Brent calm he has
somehow managed to unlock our previously
unavailable clothing in ludicrous
bundles the last quote we managed to get
before our systems anti stupidity
firewall shattered under the strain was
me no get me no get numbers too big me
make small me make bundle me make sail
markiplier spells douchebag me best me
best me best it continued on like that
for about three hours I don't know when
we're going to be able to fix this
mistake but if anyone goes to cloak
brand calm until it's fixed so you can
get some crazy bundle deals on some
clothing that you will likely never see
again and once more I am truly sorry for
Sean hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to IM fish made
by the developers of surgeon simulator
and i am bread i am bread is not a game
I agreed with it's a fine game don't get
me wrong the game is fine it's just that
I personally didn't have the best of
times with that game anyway I'm gonna
take this cool calm and collected I'm
gonna do just fine
alright swim towards the light turn
okay up down doesn't seem to be doing
much
shouldn't I be flapping oh wait no ah
Oh interesting hmm okay very fascinating
I see so this is out there's gonna be a
lot of Wang doodling of the flapper here
ah yes I remember this from the trailer
okay so all I have to do is roll the
ball at the end of the day that's all
there is to it right so if I turn flap
the ball rolls simple as that turn the
fish roll the ball and just like that
it's a thick hey I got a fish point a
fish checkpoint wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait where are
we going where we going wait a minute
wait hang on ah it's fine
we're good we're good we're good alright
so all I got to do is just play the game
just as simple as that maybe take it
nice and easy sometimes maybe get the
collectibles when they come this is
simple Oh baby could do this and I am
NOT a baby I'm a man this won't be so
bad
hey maybe this will be a fun experience
for me I wish you would just flap in the
way your fish was facing ooh too fast
too fast too fast I gotta get out the
front door I gotta get out the front
door
there I go go that way why do I turn
wait why is it turning me that ain't
right I'm on that way wait wait wait
okay if you turn in random directions
how am I supposed to be able to not
random erections random directions how
am I supposed to be able to know which
way I'm going a sort of confident
ability is this gonna be safe for me to
fall out of here yeah whatever it's too
late to care okay okay I sure wish the
the camera wasn't so mind bogglingly all
over the place ooh I see where I'm
supposed to go
this way no no no oh it's fine
okay all right we're fine I sure I'm
glad someone set up all these yoga mats
on the roof these damn city dwellers
trying to better themselves with what
little nature they have access to the
stupid fools oh please
oh no the darkness no the end now all
right
the trick is I think if I'm able to
understand what tricks are the trick is
no dad ain't the track oh just kill me
why don't I die faster is the thing what
I know I'm failed why don't I die okay
so that the trick is oh I gotta get on
this rail oh no I was so close
no the rail aah okay now I'm ready to
counteract this motion
no what what whoa whoa what why did I go
ten million miles an hour
literally you get a speed gun up there I
was going ten bajillion miles an hour
I'm doing this as gently as I possibly
can okay I'm getting there now I'm
turning around I still want to
counteract why why why
get in the hole no not there no not
there either am I supposed to get on
those rails because that seems patently
impossible also I seem to have no
consents of control once I get over the
lip of the edge I just start immediately
rolling down gravity's a [ __ ] okay I'm
ready for it
I'm ready for it wait no dad do Oh God
why good what it's impossible it's
impossible okay I'm just gonna go for it
here we go
I trust faith fate Oh whoo whoo that was
it I just got to be confident
oh there we go oh I did it yeah okay
okay which way I go whoa whoa whoa whoa
don't spin it sir
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's top job
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop I
wish I could see which direction I was
actually swimming okay we got another
checkpoint here oh I'm hoping there's a
yoga mat on the bottom of this that
would be very helpful with there oh I
see am I supposed to be able to stop
myself because I don't know if I'll be
able do okay I hope I don't let's go for
it what's the worst that could happen
fall to my doom gone in before I am
getting out of here oh oh oh oh wait
cars cars cars are a problem wait cars
cars problem cars movie but just gonna
go for it I'm flapping uh-oh
oh yeah I don't know how to look both
ways and then gun it gun it gun it hard
got it fast got it hard and fast faster
harder I'm gunning it as fast as ah I'm
fine done it harder faster gun not that
way no go across the street oh there
goes my water well I got off well no no
wait no wrong wait I was oh God
I was flapping the complete wrong way
how am I gonna do this how am I gonna do
this it doesn't really matter what I'm
trying to do cuz I'm not gonna be able
to do it right no matter which way I go
cuz I'm old maybe maybe my shot my shot
my shot come on come on come on keep
going
oh ma no no God god damn it I kept going
that way why would I go that way to you
I throw it that way too I don't know how
cameras work I was going left Oh what oh
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it I'm making it
I'm making it in baby I'm gonna count
that yeah I don't know how that happened
but I counted okay all right I can do
this I mean I didn't do that with any
semblance of skill so I can't exactly
say that I did anything cuz I don't
think doing is a big part of this I
think just hoping oh no oh no oh no oh I
just wish there was some kind of an auto
camera why do I keep getting flipped
around that's impossible
it's impossible to navigate because you
keep getting turned around how it anyway
way way way way way okay okay easy easy
ease up there Pongo ease up there Bubba
ease up there bobby-boo ease up there
okay
Bobby boo and Bobby you whoa God please
I'm cracked but I'm okay I'm not dead
yet I'm only slightly cracked okay so
not why do you keep getting turned
around this doesn't make any sense
stop getting turned around please oh oh
where am I going where am I going where
am I going oh okay I see a Tampa we know
that could be fun I don't know where
it's gonna send me maybe into the
neighbor's pool I'm gonna go for it okay
okay no why would that do that to me
because I was already cracked alright
let's try that again okay why wants Oh
God Oh
okay I'm gonna try to drop from like
higher up on it but I feel like that's
just gonna send me to my doom a little
faster wait wait wait wait I found the
way I found the way I found the way Oh
God God turn turn turn turn swim ah no
let's try that again
okay turn around know what whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy easy easy
easy easy okay I'm doing this apparently
this is happening
Oh God where are we going
am i does this count oh oh where am I
going
how also it's a good thing I don't have
much of a blame Oh what the hell did I
just find like an alternate path or
something Oh Oh God did get in the what
are you doing what are you doing get in
the water
wha yeah it's a good thing gravity is
really weird around here oh yeah
SuperSpeed and oh good jump
okay that was really pathetic rocket for
it yeah there we go
that's what I thought oh now this what
I'm talking about this is more being a
fish is all about Oh run foot because
I'm that good oh yes please thank you
I'll take all of that yes thank you also
I'm extremely handsome alright if I come
up in it oh I'm sorry what just happened
I'm in a mop bucket okay that doesn't
make sense but I'll take it
okay time to go into the woods I get oh
my god am I about to go down
yeah don't mind me just gonna take this
thing down hill skiing you know how it
is
oh boy please tell me this is how this
is gonna go well so please tell me there
aren't any like bears in the woods that
are gonna scoop me up out of this bucket
because that would be bra Matic at best
Hey what who what
who's saying Hey Oh God okay let's go
buddy let's go I didn't know that he was
coming after me oh yeah hey nothing hey
nonny nonny nonny nonny oh god I didn't
realize that would be the brother
punishment I had a rock and that happens
oh that guy's really slow I didn't
realize that was the conundrum that I
was facing there are no
bears but there's a big hairy man and I
think that's just as dangerous yeah yeah
yeah yeah buddy buddy listen I am just
too busy to even be bothered with you
right now okay so what do I gotta do I
gotta go I gotta somehow make this
corner is that what I gotta do okay
we're fine
Hey Oh God stranger danger No Oh
do that to me man that guy's a menace
okay I'm gonna take cut this in or path
here no not on the hill not on they'll
let's go let's go let's go come on come
on go go go go go go yeah yeah this way
is the winner oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die it's
fine perfect perfect perfect it's
perfect
and we're going oh god my arm is not
prepared for this kind of motion whose
[ __ ] okay this way and this way and then
round the bend
Oh God round the bend oh my god
round the bend oh my god let's go can I
get a checkpoint at literally any time
would be great okay left right right I
mean I meant left I meant right now Oh
God please not like this oh god please
he's right behind me I know he is just
go No
oh my god just go this is your chance
Oh God Hills hope God wait wait where
are the rocks I can't see okay we're
fine it's got to go this way avoid those
last rock I mean they could tip me if
they want Oh
[Music]
I did it oh my god okay let's keep it
going then this is for victory Trent oh
I don't know if I belong here that's a
lot of humours oh oh I see
interesting this is a glass ceiling or
what oh it is oh there's the exit okay
so where do I gotta go here okay
ah I see another bucket okay line myself
up and go for it
Oh what what what this is this is not
this is not how I died
ah give me in the book please I want in
the bucket oh yes I'm fine
no yeah turn the music up alright so now
I gotta look out for drunkards and
idiots scuse me bucket closes rule not
to tear up the dance floor here whoa
whoa whoa hey you ease up on those
maneuvers there buddy okay ease up on
the maneuvers buddy can I get out of
this corner please can I please get out
of this quote what is happening why am I
not why am I not going oh whoa okay can
I please just go there's my checkpoint
what no get that won't you but good
point oh come on what are you doing what
are you doing get get the checkpoint or
get whoa who are you kidding Lane get
the goddamn Jew sorry it's a fish point
that's that's where I made my first
mistake I don't know if I can go down
these stairs oh oh geez okay all right
oh okay we're fine burrow
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good okay we're good no no a
way way way wow that's really impressive
whatever you're doing but I got to get
through here Thanks checkpoint
checkpoint checkpoint checkpoint
checkpoint yes
no what why yes yes no not that way yes
checkpoint checkpoint is good
give me that give me good get me why
give me oh it already triggered
I don't know what good this is gonna do
me
this is knocking over this is no way
this is not gonna work it's an imprint
oh really really really time this
perfectly Oh God
not perfect not perfect oh okay that's
impossible there's no way to do there's
no way to do that there's no way there's
no way there's no way there is no way
I'm just getting enough speed to get
through in one go in one god damn it
okay I'm still alive holy [ __ ] oh my
wife no no no wait wait wait where you
going where you going buddies oh but in
skis whoa whoa whoa but in skis where am
I headed left I see it I see it no no no
give me the check give me the check
point
give me the check point baby come on no
turn the right way goddamn it
okay I got it this is a very not
stressful game it's very relaxing nice
and relaxing if I could turn the way I
needed to turn that is a completely
exaggerated reaction to what should have
happened when that man just stick you
lated with the barest movement of his
arm okay try this again I'm going down
I'm gonna counteract the speed with my
own tail oh yeah this is gently no not
accelerate towards him god it's slow
slow slow
there we go that's in the right
direction okay slow slow slow slow slow
easy like it weren't nothing don't touch
him like it weren't nothing because it
weren't nothing can I get a checkpoint
is there no checkpoint down here really
oh my god it's in the center oh my god
you are kidding me I can't even see it
because I'm up against the wall oh god
go go go go go go go oh god stop stop
stop stop oh god stop stop oh god okay
here we go here we go go get it get it
get it get it get it get it which way
are you pointing now oh my god no no
kitty checkpoint you're right there
oh please okay okay can you have it can
I do I have okay I got it
I don't know where I'm going next but
here I go left left left left
okay around that corner whoa whoa easy
buddy easy buddy whoa whoa whoa hey I
don't know the timing cuz I can't see
anything that's happening so I'm just
kind of guessing that now is a good time
which is probably wrong Oh God get away
from me okay go go go go go now's the
chance now is a chance now is the chance
I'm not gonna get that skill you want me
to jump out of my oh [ __ ] stop stop
you're you really want me to jump out of
my bucket just to try to get a stupid
scale for some sense of accomplishment
that I care nothing about is that what
you want
Oh what whoa what what what Oh what
you did not just drink me you seriously
did not just drink me Oh am I in control
oh no way
oh my god I am in control I could make
this man go flirt with a lady or a man I
just got to be careful about him yakking
I guess wait which way am I going I
don't think I'm supposed to be here yeah
come on buddy this way oh no no not like
that no this way you you drive horribly
okay this is pretty hilarious
I got emit this is this kind of Larry's
right up until he pisses me out which is
probably gonna happen what you marry my
supposed to what am I supposed oh okay I
get it I guess excuse me pardon me
sex machine walking through I don't know
where I am cuz the camera sucks scuse me
pardon me the camera is so garbage
that's okay well let that stop me okay
here I go
watch out air jeez okay just go buddy
just go where am I going
I'm not going up here I'm not going back
I guess it's the only way that oh really
you're gonna flip around like that you
make no sense why do you make no sense
oh my god you flipped around again why
okay I can't go up there anyway that's
why it flips around cuz I can't go there
well good I'm glad that it's so frickin
clear which way that I need to go
I'm so glad can you just go man
just go oh well there oh okay right oh
and now he's floating
and he's floated into the ether and I am
in the beyond I don't know what he's
doing I think I need to get this guy to
the bathroom before he acts which is
great cuz I'm not pointing that way I'm
literally like holding down the turn
button because that it'll just like
randomly face the complete opposite
direction and I don't know why like
there yeah I think that's the bathroom
over there I think I saw the ladies room
all lined up to hell but I'm pretty sure
I just have to do this again get in
oh my god turn turn I look I turn god
damn it I'm gonna lose my mind I'm gonna
lose my [ __ ] mind
okay clear shot from here right wrong
I'm facing the wrong way why why god
damn you
why oh my god just go oh my god just go
just [ __ ] go oh this is the most
important thing I've ever done if you
[ __ ] yak before I'm inches from there
oh my god I will not do this again I
swear to God I will not do this again
just get in there oh god where do I have
to go where do I have to go just point
me in us no that's not a stall oh my god
that's not a stall why is that not
assault where am i pointed oh my god
if you I swear to God if you oh my god I
swear to God
do not [ __ ] me over right not right here
not when I'm this [ __ ] close are you
I swear god no it's the one with the
water it's very clearly the one with the
water go in in in in in okay god oh my
god oh my god oh my god I
PAH
[Music]
my hand hurts so bad and not the hand
that I was shaking with my left hand
because I was railing on the turn oh
there we get it's all done Oh
once you've picked a direction for your
fish they will keep that direction as
long as you don't move the left control
stick that is why you would turn around
oh god no I was playing it wrong the
whole time great okay good great I was
playing it wrong the whole time
great I was my own worst enemy okay well
that's good because now I know now I
know now I know I didn't read that
before ah okay I'm out of here thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to play it
for yourself this games free link in the
description hey have you checked out a
heist with markiplier yet I talk about
it a lot but that's because I'm real
proud of it if you haven't checked it
out link is in the description or Google
all Heights with markiplier you'll find
it it's pretty cool thanks for watching
if you want to see IM bread and want to
see me in pain link in the description
or in this suggested probably i don't
know if it'll be there but maybe it's
there either way you look up Marga bar I
am bread I don't know yeah if you don't
know how to use YouTube at this point it
is I feel like this is a you problem
thank you everybody someone for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]